so cool who Allah say he lost one God is  one the maker of mankind exactly a lot  was somewhat lost self-sufficient he  doesn't need food or drink he doesn't  need to rest on the seventh day ok I  really had a problem with that even  before i do anything about a slump god  resting sounds like a week guy yeah  Lamia lid while I'm you like he begets  not he doesn't have any children nor was  he a child or born of anything or anyone  well I'm yeah cool off before I had and  there's nothing co-equal or comparable  to him at all nobody nothing Jesus  nobody nobody's comparable to the crater  nothing yeah and that right there was in  his essence what I believe naturally  you